[Music]
it is a scandal that has already claimed
thousands of lives are lost machines
shatter ski and many more will die
before a public inquiry reaches its
conclusion every year there's less and
less and less of it but after a 40-year
wait for answers I'd like to think that
they will find the truth the stories of
the victims living and dead are finally
being heard yeah that's the moment and
that was Headmaster's office staff rooms
aide Steve and Gary have returned to the
school that was supposed to transform
their lives but ended up threatening
them or going into hospital and being
treated like something with true laws
College is a specialist school within
the 1970s and 80s welcomed haemophiliac
boys through those green doors and
matters where the college ends and yeah
it offered an education and
revolutionary treatment but in an NHS
run clinic they were given contaminated
blood products that gave them HIV and
hepatitis C of more than 80 boys they
are among just 16 who are still alive
when I first arrived it was incredible
it was the most amazing place I've ever
seen
35 acres of countryside a great big
mansion jacobi a mansion doctors physios
nurses treatment on demand it was an
amazing place for tenure a boy to be it
was a great time you grew up with your
friends from the age of 10 and to 18 we
played football cricket 100% attendance
record because if you had a bleed and
that's happy transfuse with your
injections that would take between 15
minutes and half an hour and you would
literally go back to school just after
breakfast about just about quarter to
9:00 half eight something like that we'd
all prance down to the sickbay stand
outside the door and then you'd go in
and there'd be three or four tables
ready
with syringes on full of factory bearing
in mind we were children I think nine
years old and we weren't really told a
lot about it really
they just said there's this new product
on now and it's going to change your
life and yes it did at that time but
obviously now we realized that it's
killed a lot of us we were told that for
some of us and that we met HIV and they
told us by that go learn the River Seine
you have you haven't you have you
haven't you have I was told that I had
HIV in 83 me and friend Steve just went
in the room and matter-of-factly you've
been infected with HIV we don't know
anything about it and we can't say for
certain how long you're going to live
for around 1983 1984 when the link had
been made between HIV AIDS and
hemophilia overnight hemophilia became a
dirty word we were scared we could see
what was going on we realized this link
had been made and it could be us I'm the
last event in personal life in that room
today it was difficult to come back to
the reunions and things rather have
because you're not sure who's gonna be
there it's destroyed everyone's lives
the infected blood inquiry is examining
what happened to the true laws boys and
to nearly five thousand other people
infected in the UK nearly 3,000 of them
have died some of their names recorded
in this memorial at the inquiries
headquarters contaminated factor eight
made from blood plasma was imported in
the 1970s and 80s much of it from the
United States where it was collected
from prisoners sex workers and drug
users who were paid for their blood
professor Ted Tottenham was a senior
hematologist at the Royal Free Hospital
in London he says that fact
eight promised to revolutionize the
treatment of hemophilia having a
apparently clean concentrated stable
easily available readily made up easily
infused product was an enormous advance
not just in convenience but in efficacy
he says he had no idea about
contamination until it was too late the
awareness that were so many of our
patients had been infected was
[Music]
devastating more safe for them than for
us but it certainly was devastating for
us
the patients were beginning to die Lee
was a very telogen bright boy the brains
of his mother yeah he's very clever glad
Lee Turton was diagnosed with
haemophilia at six months old he
contracted HIV from factor 8 aged four
he died when he was 10 when they called
us in to speak to us the consultant just
said straightaway we've done a blood
test he's HIV positive and we know as
much as you know but we'd already months
before that I've been asking how safe
the treatment worse because we'd heard
that it was in the blood products I
would say up to four four now he is fine
five then course the issues with the
school you know and that would affect
him and then he started hurting him
inside that you know his friends would
didn't want to speak to him they must go
near him teachers didn't want to teach
him and the press with Pastor in the
house we got to move in young because
yet even walking yeah if he went to the
shops there was people wouldn't go near
you and then there was a couple of
people that said he'd be better off dead
it seemed to come very quickly in the
end you know all right I'll say eighteen
months to year he started it started to
fade on us somebody had robbed him of
his childhood I mean he was dying in
front of our eyes and we just couldn't
do anything and every time we took him
to the
hospital because he wasn't feeling very
well nobody seemed to care I feel guilty
maybe I should have you know done more
for him we put our trust in the
hospitals the doctors it's maybe I
should've asked more questions I blame
the pharmaceutical companies I blame the
civil servants and I blame the
government because they covered it all
up to profit
establishing who was responsible for the
greatest treatment scandal in the
history of the NHS is a central question
for the inquiry it is a huge undertaking
the largest public inquiry ever
conducted in the UK with around 150
staff combing through records dating
back 40 years and more than a thousand
witness statements these are just some
of almost two and a half million pages
of NHS records that will be examined by
the inquiry and there are more than five
million more documents from other
agencies yet to come all part of the
process of establishing what doctors
officials and ministers knew about
contaminated blood and when they knew it
survivors victims and their families
have long suspected a cover-up
and they want the inquiry to ask
questions right at the very top there's
absolutely no doubt that former Prime
Minister's have to be questioned as to
why this happened and the initial views
taken by the Thatcher administration
were carried on by the by her successor
John Major and John Major is still alive
and kicking and certainly the victims
are very very keen to see him called to
give evidence and answer the questions
which they feel they have wanted to ask
him for the last 40 years but there's a
nice variety there Simon Hamilton is
chairman of haemophilia Northern Ireland
he was infected with hepatitis C and has
cirrhosis of the liver emotionally and
physically on me directly it has had a
number of impacts I'm currently going
through counselling support it's like a
the top of a jar being knocked off now
that the public inquiries there and all
these emotions which I thought I I
didn't have or I thought I had
controlled those those those have come
out every six months I'm tested to see
if there's a a tumour or the start of a
tumour which means liver cancer and then
the consequences of that so for me those
are the realities the reality for my
family and my son my wife
they bear they bear the worry and they
also watch and and they live with that -
so it's uninsured with my mother and my
brothers my twin brother ended up with
liver cancer and required a transplant
and I was with him through all of that
that is something I wouldn't wish on
anyone and there are many people who've
gone through that who've gone through
that and for them I shared tears and for
those who did not survive I shared tears
I'm angry yes I'm I'm I feel betrayed by
those who had a responsibility of due
diligence to look after people like me
and those others who are not here any
longer like every other victim he knows
this may be the best and last chance for
answers the brothers and sisters if you
like in this process
I don't think we'll settle for another
whitewash on determined by the truth
from the truth will come out we've lost
so many people so yes the promise and
the bonds were made this is what this is
about the people that actually did cover
up
what happened
should be punished hopefully its inquiry
will give us some justice and some peace
[Music]